bonjour à tous nous sommes ensemble pour
45 minutes pour faire le tour de
l'actualité politique et parlementaire
bonjour michaëlle jean pierre ils ont
voté contre des textes emblématiques du
gouvernement les retraites et le budget
ont dit non au cumul des mandats mais
uniquement pour les députés les
sénateurs frondeurs se sont fait
remarquer cette année mais l'an prochain
les choses pourraient bien changer avec
en vue les élections sénatoriales du
syndicalisme à la politique
edouard martin sera tête de liste
socialiste pour les européennes dans le
grand est la leader des métallos de
florange a accepté la proposition ps une
candidature très polémique on parlera
également des élections municipales avec
un sondage qui donne anne hidalgo
gagnent entre à paris face à nathalie
kosciusko morizet et puis le plus de
parlement hebdo vous emmène en immersion
chez pôle emploi avec les employés de l'
agence de saint denis en ile-de-france
la détresse au travail qui conduit
parfois à des actes extrêmes comme
l'immolation par le feu de reportages
inédits sont diffusées ce mois ci sur
les chaînes parlementaires est notre
invité pour commenter toute cette
actualité faire un peu le bilan aussi de
cette année 2013 vos jours pedro
bonjour sénateurs secrétaire nationale
du parti communiste vous avez été réélu
le week-end dernier à la tête de la
gauche européenne ce qui n'a pas fait
visiblement que des heureux au sein du
front de gauche on va en reparler
je vous propose d'abord d'écouter ce
témoignage s'agit d'andré chassaigne ne
pas trop des députés communistes à
l'assemblée nationale puis vous réagirez
juste après je pense que le front de
gauche doit continuer mais en se mettant
d'accord sur une stratégie parce que la
divergence vient pour l'essentiel d'une
différence de stratégie
est ce que le front de gauche doit avoir
un rôle au sein de la gauche pour que la
gauche soit orientée vers une autre
politique que on puisse être utile
efficace avoir un rôle à jouer
aujourd'hui
ou est ce que le front de gauche doit
uniquement
sur une forme de radicalité
recroquevillée sur elle-même avec des
grands élans tribune sans pour autant
peser sur le cours de la politique
aujourd'hui pour mieux comprendre le
parti de gauche les amis de jean luc
mélenchon décidé de suspendre leur
participation à la gauche aux
européennes suite à votre reconduction
j'avoue que c'est assez compliqué mais
la question est très simple
est ce que le front de gauche est mort
non pas du tout je pense que le front
gauche va d'autant plus continuer que on
voit bien qu'il ya la politique
gouvernementale et très massivement
rejeté ou discuter dans les rangs de la
gauche elle-même
il ya de plus en plus de gens qui
s'interrogent sur ce cap est donc qui
cherchent la voie d'une alternative anti
austérité à gauche donc le front de
gauche qui est sur cette position depuis
le premier jour a vocation à continuer
et c'est ce qu'on reproche à vous faire
visiblement les amis de jean luc
mélenchon sait écouter d'avancé sur la
façon dont vous avez fait paris c'est à
dire un accord avec le gouvernement la
regrette avec le gouvernement contre le
gouvernement on entend donc sur la
question européenne où je viens d'être
élu président du parti de la gauche
européenne
on vient de prendre une décision très
importante avec 33 parti de la gauche
européenne
c'est d'aller tous ensemble aux
élections européennes pour faire
progresser la gauche anti austérité et
on a même décidé de ceux d'avoir un
candidat à la présidence de la
commission européenne ensemble le leader
de syriza en grèce alexis tsipras ce
donc c'est vrai que c'est assez
incompréhensible qu au moment où y ait
ce mouvement de rassemblement de la
gauche européenne liée la décision du
parti de gauche qui je crois est pas
très bien comprise et que mes mais nous
allons aller je pense que toutes les
voiles géantes en dise nous allons aller
ensemble aux élections à régler avec
jean luc mélenchon vous y retrouverait
pour les élections il faut savoir on est
dans un moment très difficile pour le
pays et pour l'europe
donc moi je pense qu'il faut savoir
aller au delà de tel ou tel des accords
de telle ou telle polémique
c'est beaucoup plus important beaucoup
plus important de se rassembler surtout
quand on est d'accord sur l'essentiel
c'est à dire qu'il faut tourner la page
de l'austérité donc il peut ya voir tel
ou tel débat mais par rapport à ce qu on
a en commun par rapport aux besoins
on se rassembler pour imposer une autre
politique tout ça me paraît assez mineur
cause commune moi je continuerai sur la
démarche qui est la mienne je ne veux
pas valoriser ce qui fait la différence
sur tel ou tel point
j'ai envie de mettre en avant ce qui
nous est commun et de continuer le front
de gauche au plan européen avec la
gauche européenne et en france avec
l'ensemble des forces du front de gauche
confie qu'il s'est passé c'est pas
compliqué c'est assez simple de dire qu'
il peut y avoir des différences et des
débats dans le front de gauche mais que
ce qui nous est commun et plus important
surtout dans la situation de crise que
connaît le pays
donc il faut mettre l'accent sur ça et
travailler ensemble avancer ensemble
en face à l'actualité parlementaire on
va faire le bilan de cette année dame
états avec évidemment vous êtes sénateur
ou la vue la fronde des sénateurs
ils se sont opposés sur des textes
majeurs de cette fin d'année budget
retraite cumul des mandats les sénateurs
n'ont pas peur de porter le fer contre
le gouvernement extrait de séance agitée
avec jean baptise à aulas c'est une
forteresse imprenable pour le
gouvernement le sénat est à gauche
mais le ps doit composer avec les
communistes pour avoir la majorité
résultat des projets de loi qui traverse
un parcours du combattant
le budget est systématiquement rejetées
par les communistes et l'ump
d'autres projets de loi sont vidés de
leur substance pour les députés
socialistes le sénat est devenu un
triangle des bermudes
compte tenu de la difficulté à
construire des majorités parce qu'il est
extrêmement difficile de prévoir les
comportements de nos alliés nous avons
que peu de lisibilité donc voilà le
triangle est emmené dans un endroit où
disparaissent les bateaux il peut
arriver que des textes de loi qui
paraissent cohérent et ficelé dans le
pays a besoin disparaissent parce que le
sénat ne les a pas voté en 2013 les
échecs du gouvernement au sénat ont été
nombreux
en mars les sénateurs votent la loi sur
la tarification de l'énergie mais après
avoir supprimé le bonus malus en
septembre les sénateurs votent la fin du
cumul des mandats mais seulement pour
les députés pour l'adoption 214
entre 1 82 une nouvelle perte de temps
pour manuel valls le texte sera adopté
in fine et par alors vous avez raison
d'un pronostic que je fais et pour finir
une année de guérilla parlementaire n'a
voté la réforme des retraites de marisol
touraine
encore une fois le texte a été vidé de
sa substance et les comportements
bizarres des fois au sénat avec des
majorités qui sont des majorités
totalement de circonstance amaral enquis
par le travail parlementaire au
contraire quelquefois ça l'accélère même
les textes nous reviennent parce qu'une
motion de procédure
maintenant je pense que le sénat ne se
rend pas service en ne jouant pas son
rôle pour débattre au fond quelquefois
sur quelques textes mais ça
cette affaire de sénateurs 2014 sera une
année tournant pour le sénat
la moitié des sièges seront renouvelés
au mois de septembre alors pierre
laurent depuis votre arrivée au sénat on
va mettre les sénateurs multiplie les
initiatives contre le gouvernement il
rejette plusieurs grands est comme ça
est ce que ces deux événements sont liés
est-ce que c'est voulu
j'ai pas j'ai pas ce pouvoir là moi tout
seul loin de là mais des sièges arrière
je voudrais dire un mot les propos de
bruno le roux sont assez méprisant pour
le sénat et qui les présentera cinq ans
on est président d'un groupe
parlementaire important
on devrait éviter de tenir ce genre de
propos qu'est ce qui se passe c'est très
simple en fait il y a une majorité à
l'aso sénat qui est une majorité de
gauche est effectivement aucun groupe
n'a la majorité à lui tout seul à gauche
les socialistes ont besoin pour faire
une majorité que les verts et les
communistes soient d'accord sur les
projets de loi ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire qu'un projet pour être adopté au
sénat
à la différence de l'assemblée nationale
où les socialistes sont majoritaires au
sous sol pour être adopté au sénat doit
être un texte de gauche et bien encore
le texte n'est pas un texte de gauche il
n'est pas adoptée par le sénat
revendiqué par al dans la place senna
retraites la réforme des retraites n'a
pas été adopté au sénat parce que tout
simplement ce texte n'a pas de majorité
à gauche
pas plus que la réforme sur les eaux
vient de voter la réforme sur les
métropoles la réforme institutionnelle
qui est une réforme très importante pour
le moment dont les gens n'entendent pas
bien parler mais qui aura des beaucoup
de conséquences et bien ce texte a été
adopté qu'avec les voix de la droite
tout simplement parce que ce n'est pas
un texte de gauche et le sénat ça n'est
pas une majorité introuvable c'est celle
qui a permis l'élection de françois
hollande
sans les communistes et sans les verts
françois hollande n'était pas élue elle
s'en fout mais je n'étais pas élu donc
au sénat travailler avec nous à des
textes de gauche 1 devrait être une
bonne règle pour être fidèle à ce qu'a
voulu le bien qu'ils ne travaillent pas
suffisamment avec vous il ne vous écoute
pas suffisamment ça veut dire que le
gouvernement fait sans le sénat et sans
les communes le gouvernement pense trop
souvent que parce qu'il a une majorité
socialiste à l'assemblée nationale
il peut se passer de discuter avec
l'ensemble des formations de gauche et
c'est un très mauvais service qu'ils
aient rendu à la gauche est
effectivement alors il ya des textes qui
sont rejetés parce que ils n'ont pas de
majorité il y en a quelques-uns qui soit
qui sont adoptées nous nous votons des
textos c'est là nous avons voté le texte
de cécile duflot sur le logement
nous votons d'autres textes sur le cumul
des mandats
si le texte a été rejeté c'est pas de
notre faute on était même les seuls à
être extrêmement clair contre le cumul
des mandats
donc il ya des bestioles qui sont
validés ils sont bonnes je vous avais
achetés notamment la fameuse réforme des
retraites alors à la différence du sénat
alors n'en parle justement la différence
du sénat l'assemblée a adopté la réforme
à l'issue d'un ultime vote des députés à
main levée vous le voyez alors on le
disait elle avait été rejetée deux fois
par le sénat
mais puisque les députés ont le dernier
mot est donc passé principale mesure
l'allongement de la durée de cotisation
à 43 ans la création d'un conte
pénibilité beaucoup de mesures aussi
pour en faveur des métiers pénibles
meilleure prise en compte des stages du
temps partiel vous ne pensez c'est pas
une vraie réforme de gauche pour vous ça
n'a pas du tout l'allongement de la
durée de cotisation qui est le coeur de
la réforme va pénaliser très gravement
une majorité des salariés et on sait ce
que ça signifie parce que quarante trois
années de cotisation pour avoir une
retraite à taux plein ça veut dire que
soit on prend sa retraite
compte tenu de la joie dans lequel on
entre aujourd'hui réellement dans la vie
active soit pour la grande majorité des
salariés on va prendre sa retraite à 65
à 66 ans soit on va on va prendre sa
retraite avec une grosse décote
autrement dit une pension amputée et on
sait que c'est ça puisque déjà avec les
réformes de droite précédente
quand on a allongé la durée de
cotisation on aboutit progressivement à
une baisse du niveau moyen des pensions
comment le problème est mathématique
démographique comment vous faites pour
assurer la pérennité financière nous
avons mis des propositions sur la reine
nous les avions mis on déjà sur la table
en 2010 et nous les avons remis des
propositions de financement nouveaux par
exemple nous nous compétition position
ça crée une cotisation sur les revenus
financiers des entreprises
ça rapporte énormément d'argent parce
que les revenus financiers des
entreprises qui sont en explosion avec
la financiarisation de l'économie ne
contribue pas au financement de la
protection sociale les cotisations
sociales dont sont aujourd'hui à 6 que
sur la partie salariale mais tous les
revenus financiers des entreprises
échappent les avaient pas été entendu
par amis du parti socialiste entre haute
et de la batterie parce que la réforme
est resté sur des principes qui étaient
déjà ceux de la réforme de 2010 de
sarkozy et je pense que les gens qui
l'ont élu françois hollande
les gens qui y c'est une occurrence est
une réforme qui prolonge les réformes de
droite de balladur et sarkosy et les
gens qui ont élu ce gouvernement
s'attendait à tout autre chose et nous
avons nous été fidèle au mandat
qu'avaient donné les électeurs de gauche
à la majorité tandis que le gouvernement
lui a tourné le dos à ses électeurs
quand on vous propose de passer au mardi
avec une candidature pour les
européennes qui a fait beaucoup de bruit
le parti socialiste a choisi sa tête de
liste pour les européennes dans le grand
test il s'agit d' edouard martin
syndicalistes de cfdt mittal il avait
pourtant vivement critiqué le
gouvernement à l'époque sur la gestion
du dossier florange où a résumé de gérer
hartmann et on en parle juste après un
visage un gilet orange et une voix
j'espère j'espère que la france va
comprendre
jusqu'à hier édouard martin c'était ce
syndicaliste cfdt prête à tout pour
sauver les hauts fourneaux de florange
incarnation de la colère des métallos
démunis face à la mort annoncée de leur
outil de travail
il n'hésitait pas à menacer directement
le président françois hollande en
septembre 2012 pour qu'il tienne ses
promesses de campagne
vous attendez quoi qu'il y à malheur ici
bas nous nous arrêtent votre malheur
depuis l'homme s'est semble-t-il
réconcilier avec les socialistes au
point d'accepter fière de porter leurs
couleurs aux prochaines européennes
oui je serai peut-être de liste sur
liste socialiste de grossesse j'ai
accepté la proposition qui m'a été fait
j'ai simplement envie de continuer le
combat que nous menons depuis maintenant
plusieurs années notamment sur le
maintien de l'industrie en france sur
l'europe alors edouard martin at il
profité de son parcours syndical
l'at-il utilisé comme marchepied pour se
lancer en politique à ses ex camarades
de lutte qui se sentent trahis
voici ce que répond l'intéressé je ne
renie rien et je n'enlève rien à ce que
nous avons dit ce que nous avons fait
mais les organisations syndicales ne
sont pas les seuls à douter de sa
sincérité
côté politique la droite se montre tout
aussi sceptique c'est pas aux
syndicalistes de faire de la politique
sur le fond je trouve qu'il y a une très
grande contradiction dans ses positions
en même temps je ne m'autorise à aucun
mépris à l'égard d'un candidat ou seul
motif qu'il était syndicaliste
avant d'être élu on est tous quelque
chose à la sortie du conseil des
ministres
c'est aurélie filippetti elle aussi
originaire de lorraine qui est venu
voler au secours des douars martin sa
sincérité elle n'est pas en doute
il a dit les choses qui ne voulait dire
au moment où il voulait dire
et aujourd'hui s'il s'engage c'est parce
qu'il est convaincu de la politique que
l'on est en train de mettre en place
edouard martin une prise de guerre au
profil idéal pour le parti socialiste
qui cherche à redorer son image auprès
d'un électorat ouvrier déçu par le début
de quinquennat de françois hollande
alors pierre laurent est ce que c'est un
coup pour edouard martin ou une belle
prise du parti socialiste est est ce que
edouard martin ferait un bon député
européen non mais c'est pas moi plus
c'est pas vrai qu'il est critiqué
l'entrée on nourrit d'un ouvrier aux
politiques d'un ouvrier en plus il en
manque beaucoup
des ouvriers dans le monde politique
donc que qu'un syndicaliste ouvriers
décident ne franchir le pas non enfin
non pas au parti communiste
il ya beaucoup d'ouvriers qui sont
engagés qui conduisent des listes aux
municipales et dans les listes du parti
communiste donc moi je me félicite de ça
maintenant
edouard martin va se débrouiller ça
c'est son problème avec ses
contradictions c'est à dire qu'il a dit
beaucoup de choses sur la politique du
gouvernement
à ma connaissance cette politique n'a
pas fondamentalement changé par rapport
à l'époque où il à critiquer donc c'est
à lui de se débrouiller avec ces
infections
mais ça fait partie mais ça fait partie
du débat politique
moi je préfère qu'on ait ce débat
politique en toute franchise et qu' on
est des gens qui s'engagent dans le
combat politique
et puis après c'est le débat les
électeurs les électeurs choisiront
gélules edouard glissant a dit a dit
j'ai lu ce qu'il dit il dit qu'il a
toujours voté socialiste donc ça veut
dire que en 2012 il a voté françois là
où vous n'auriez pas aimé les rassure
vos listes mais vous savez moi je jeu il
ya beaucoup de syndicalistes qui sont
drôles front de gauche qui sont parti
communiste qui s'engagent du prêtre les
responsabilités et il y en a beaucoup
on parle pas énormément et qui sont pas
aussi médiatisé qui edouard martin mais
qui sont très engagés je vais dans beau
sur beaucoup de sites où il ya des
conflits et il y en a beaucoup qui
s'engagent à nos côtés
edouard martin pour le pf nadine morano
pour lui-même et florian philippot pour
le front national là je parle du grand
test vous présenter quelques uns ou pas
sur cette partie bien sûr mais là on va
présenter des quelqu'un de partout mais
on n'a pas encore décidé dans le front
de gauche les têtes de lit ça va se
décider en janvier donc au mois de
janvier on va avoir la discussion sur
nos têtes de liste dans le dos et dans
le grand test s'est pas encore décidé ça
vous choque pas ces récompenses que ce
soit à gauche ou à droite comme
notamment nadine morano qui fait beau la
candidature évoqué dans le grand est qui
fait beaucoup parler
est ce que ça vous est ce que ça vous
chante mais c'est pas une question de
vie ou de récompense et j'ai ça c'est
enfin excusez moi de vous dire ça à vous
mais c'est cesser les médias qui font de
cette espèce de médiatisation personnel
nadine morano elle et de cette région
je suis en désaccord à peu près complet
sur tout ce qu'elle raconte est souvent
elle tient des propos horribles
elle est cette région elle est militante
ump elle est dédiée candidat moi je
n'aurais pas d affaires de l'ump
bon après c'est bafé aux élections
municipales si vous le voulez bien
laisser notre zone de la semaine bonjour
frédéric d'avis bonjour vous êtes
directeur général de l'institut ifop
vous n'a passé un partenariat avec vous
notamment pour un sondage qui est paru
cette semaine avec paris match on va le
détail et ensemble si vous le voulez
bien sondage sur paris le tête à tête
anne hidalgo nathalie kosciusko morizet
je vous laisse la parole qui arrive en
tête qui est premier et deuxième
alors anne hidalgo arrive en tête au
premier tour et une sorte de micro
climat à paris c'est à dire que
l'impopularité de l'exécutif
l'éventualité d'un vote sanction ne
trouve pas de résonance à paris anne
hidalgo
les listes ps parti communiste prg
arrive en tête 39 % contre 38 % pour les
dix nathalie kosciusko morizet ce qui
est assez intéressant c'est qu'en dépit
de l'accord récent à l'ump
udi modem qui donnait un potentiel
électorale peut-être supérieur nathalie
kosciusko morizet par rapport au parti
socialiste qui part avec le parti
communiste mais sans les écologistes
sans le parti de gauche pour autant
nathalie kosciusko morizet est devancé à
hidalgo arrive en tête
elle progresse par rapport aux mesures
précédentes hélas est liée à l'alliance
avec le parti communiste a justement
avoir parlé parce que là on voit aussi
le front de gauche est crédité de 5% le
parti communiste avait décidé d'aller
directement au premier tour faire
alliance arc bouche le parti de gauche
c'est pareil mais pas de front de gauche
à paris le parti de gauche obtient 5% il
faut mettre en regard aux 12 % obtenus
par jean luc mélenchon à l'élection
parce que résidence et voilà vont
directement à un galgo dans le sondage
on voit que sur 100 électeurs jean luc
mélenchon de l'élection présidentielle
45 % vont directement ce la liste ps pc
les électeurs de jean luc mélenchon de
la présidence elle vend plutôt sur la
liste anne hidalgo en termes de
cohérence puisque déjà en 2008 il y
avait eu une alliance ps pc et anne
hidalgo se rapprochent notamment grâce à
l'alliance avec le parti communiste avec
le prg du score de bertrand delanoë qui
a obtenu 41 ans et demi en 2008 le parti
communiste a raison d'aller dès le
premier tour avec additionnel bien sûr
pas à moi de dire si le parti communiste
à raison ou à tort en tout cas en terme
de rapport de force électoral
il est favorable au parti socialiste et
au parti communiste malgré l'alliance
ump udi modem nathalie kosciusko morizet
n'arrive pas à casser une sorte de
plafond de verre qui lui permettrait
d'arriver en tête et de créer une
dynamique surtout et c'est un autre
sujet elle a un problème sérieux avec le
front national
alors parlons donc de l'alliance avec le
ps donc pour paris vous avez choisi
d'aller ensemble à ces élections
municipales je ne pensais pas que le que
c'est plutôt le ca a plutôt profité au
parti socialiste dont mes batailles
serrées pour situer les choses on n'a
pas choisi cette stratégie d'alliance
dès le premier tour dans toutes les
villes de france ça serrait on a on a
regardé ville par ville
on a regardé ville par ville en se
disant que nous notre boussole serait où
l intérêt des populations
les bilans municipaux et les programmes
municipaux à venir donc on a mené une
discussion dans le front gauche mais on
a aussi mené une discussion avec nos
partenaires socialistes appareils
puisque ça fait deux mandats qu'on est
dans la majorité municipale appareils et
pour ce qu'il ya un bilan sur lequel on
dans lequel on a joué un rôle notamment
sur la question du logement social des
transports et d'autres et comme on a
obtenu les engagements pour poursuivre
cette politique là et amplifier une
politique d'investissements publics à l
inverse de ce qui se fait au niveau du
gouvernement on a pensé qu'on serait
plus utile en faisant ça à paris et ça
n'empêche pas dans d'autres villes
les choses vont se faire autrement une
autre vue qu'il faut le dire de cette
formule c'est attendre en tous les cas
de figure et ça là je ne parle pas
seulement du parti communiste et du
front de gauche
à l'arrivée le front de gauche je veux
contribuer à des victoires de la gauche
par tous parce qu'il y aura partout des
deuxième tour s'il ya les stratégies
témoigné tour qui sont différents d'une
ville à l'autre
mais tout ça pour concourir à des
victoires de la gauche évidemment avec
des contenus qui nous conviennent ainsi
va la vie d'amour peut-être sur
l'ensemble du front de gauche parti
communiste est ce que vous estimez des
chances sérieuses pour ces élections
municipales on est très variable bien
sûr selon selon les villes
kalhoro cela dit il y à des villes où le
front de gauche par seul sur le parti
socialiste par exemple à marseille où
ils ont un bon candidat jeu marc coppola
qui est installée depuis longtemps sur
la vie de la ville de linselles en tout
cas pour les majorité municipale
sortante ou psp ces fonds allianz a
constitué un puce pour le maire
socialiste sortante puisque ça permet de
raconter une histoire d'inscrire la
campagne dans un dans un bilan et
poursuivre le travail engagé en tout cas
sur sur paris je ne voudrais pas j'ai
pas à juger la stratégie des militants
communistes qui ont voté pour l'alliance
avec le parti socialiste
c'est un plus pour les listes alliés
daliot à l'ordre haletant d'andorre
parler on va s'intéresser un dossier en
discussion à l'assemblée mercredi le
dossier goodyear
la fermeture programmée de l'usiné
goodyear d'amiens nord est dû au manque
de dialogue social c'est l'une des
conclusions de la commission denquête de
l'assemblée nationale mise en place en
juin dernier
elle met notamment en cause la direction
de l'usiné coûté à linge est le
président de cette commission
il ya eu l'an dernier en 2012 un projet
de un plan de départs volontaires très
avantageux puisque on en a découvert
pendant la commission d'en tête les
montants des primes qui auraient été
accordés plus une reprise à hauteur de
pas loin de 50 % du personnel qui là
encore a été refusée par le syndicat
majoritaire
et là il ya une vraie vraie occasion
manquée un groupe titan ne pourrait
envisager une reprise qu'une fois le
site définitivement fermé en tout cas je
pense que toute la commission étaient
unanimes pour dire même 333 ça va mieux
que zéro salariés au travail à partir de
vous êtes d'accord avec cette analyse
même 63 ça vaut mieux que zéro salarié
contre évidemment on peut dire les
choses comme ça mais le problème c'est
qu'on aurait pu maintenir ou pourrait
maintenir l'ensemble de l'emploi
si on avait eu une autre vision
industrielle les pij est une question à
poser à monsieur geste parce qu'il nous
dit manque de dialogue social mais alors
faut qu'ils m'expliquent pourquoi lui et
et d'autres ont soutenu l'accord de
lagny et les lois qu'on a voté au
printemps dernier contre notre avis au
parlement qui réduisent tous les temps
de consultation qui empêche les comités
d'entreprise d'avoir le temps suffisant
pour pour proposer des contre expertises
alors que nous nous proposions
exactement inverse c'est ce qu'on aurait
dû faire la gauche
eh bien c'était donner des pouvoirs
supplémentaires aux salariés parce que
chez bourdieu
d'ailleurs comme ailleurs le problème
c'est que les salariés aux naucelle et
leur syndicat et leur comité
d'entreprise on ne cesse de réduire leur
pouvoir de proposer des plans
alternatifs
on devrait rendre par exemple
obligatoire la discussion sur les plans
alternatifs déposée par les salariés on
devrait donner une préférence au plan
proposé par les salariés or là on fait
l'inversé c'est toujours les
actionnaires qui ont dernier mot or dans
des cas comme ceux là on voit bien ce
sont des actionnaires financiers qui se
moque totalement de la question
industrielle et du maintien des emplois
industriels mais qui regarde qu'une
seule chose c'est leur courbe de
rentabilité bah tant qu on inversera pas
le centre de gravité des pouvoirs on
aura ce type de problèmes et de
médiation il ya le plus de pouvoir pour
les salariés pour que je peux parler
d'opposition en tout cas d'un mot ils
étaient réunis en séminaire cette
semaine l'ump veut préparer l'alternance
pour 2017 a fait un certain nombre de
propositions thibault le floch jean
françois copé était l'invité du 20
heures de tf1 pour exposer les mesures
d'urgence que propose l'ump dans
l'optique de redresser la france
il est très simple c'est d'un côté de
travailler plus donc de sortir
définitivement les 35 heures
courage de le faire est l'autre grande
idée c'est de baisser massivement les
impôts et les charges en baissant les
dépenses publiques
quelques heures auparavant l'équipe
dirigeante de l'ump s'étaient réunis en
séminaire pour arrêter une dizaine de
mesures simples concrètes et lisible
dans trois domaines l'emploi la
compétitivité et les finances publiques
l'objectif montrer que le parti ne fait
pas que s'opposer au gouvernement mais
qu'il peut aussi proposer des solutions
c'est une vision de long terme qu'est ce
que peut devenir notre pays qu'est ce
qu'on propose ce long terme qu'est ce
que va devenir la france sur trois
devraient s'appuyer
voilà pour le travail sur le fond mais
il y a également la forme
l'autre objectif de ce séminaire c'est
d'afficher une image d'unité
jean françois copé assis à côté de
françois fillon
l'image est plutôt rare ces derniers
temps pour être signalé car la droite
restent agités par les ambitions
personnelles de plusieurs de ses cadres
qui ont dans leur ligne de mire
l'élection présidentielle de 2017
un seul mot dans la bouche des membres
de l'ump rassemblement l'opposition doit
être rassemblé et doit avoir un projet
donc aujourd'hui on entame un travail de
réflexion commun sur le projet sur la
crédibilité de l'opposition sommes
rassemblés aujourd'hui tout le monde est
là au total c'est peut-être la période
des fêtes qui commence un miracle de
noël va-t-il permettre de pacifier les
relations à l'ump
l'avenir le dira du côté des
propositions politiques
les grandes orientations du parti seront
officiellement fixée lors du prochain
conseil national de l'ump le 25 janvier
prochain pour une question très simple
l'opposition est de retour vous tremblez
oui je crois qu'il ya absolument rien de
neuf dans ce que propose la droite c'est
quand on entend copé nous dire il va
falloir travailler plus et est le credo
de sarkozy en 2007
je rappelle que sous la droite on a
perdu sept cent mille emplois
industriels en france donc leur projet
c'est simple c'est surexploitées de plus
en plus ceux qui ont un boulot est
laissée au chômage ou dans la précarité
un nombre croissant de salariés
si c'est ça le projet de société de la
droite et malheureusement c'est ça et
bien évidemment il faudra leur refuser
quand ils essaieront de revenir pour
vous ultra-libéral ses skis et c'est ce
qu'on voit enfin en france et ce qu'on
voit en europe
c'est ce qui met l'europe entière dans
la récession tout le monde est en train
de le reconnaître
il va falloir sortir de ces politiques
dans d'austérité d'un côté et de
compétitivité par écrasement du coût du
travail de l'autre sens démentira pas de
pierre laurent puisque vous êtes aussi à
la tête du pge donc le parti de la
gauche européenne alors un gros merkel
est toujours là elle a prêté serment
devant les députés allemands pour son
troisième mandat consécutif à la tête de
la première puissance économique du
continent et c'est la coutume la
chancelière a retrouvé son homologue
français elle a réservé sa première
sortie à son partenaire français
un gala merkel la femme la plus
puissante d'europe
la chancelière est en position de force
à quelques heures du sommet de bruxelles
mais pas de sujets qui fâchent
officiellement paris et berlin sont sur
la même longueur d'onde du tour nous est
donné madame merkel pour quatre ans
nous pour un peu moins mais nous avons
un horizon commun qui doit devenir un
agenda commun car l'europe a besoin de
la relation entre la france et
l'allemagne la france compte sur la
nouvelle coalition au pouvoir à berlin
pour infléchir la politique européenne
fondée sur la rigueur économique
un gala merkel se dit prête au
changement mais sous conditions elle
plaide pour une évolution des traités
européens qui donnerait plus de
compétence à bruxelles une idée jusqu'à
présent rejetée par la france
je sais que c'est difficile pour
certains pays de changer les traités
mais qui veut plus d'europe doit être
prêt à déléguer certaines compétences
pour ce nouveau mandat de quatre ans la
chancelière conservatrice gouvernera
avec les sociaux démocrates qui ont
accepté de faire alliance avec son parti
leur chef sigmar gabriel a été investie
ministre de l'économie et vice
chancelier il plaide notamment pour une
europe plus sociale
mais un homme est reconduit à un poste
clé l'inflexible wolfgang schaüble le
ministre des finances est garant de la
rigueur allemande à la gauche française
il faut même excès espérer que l'entrée
des sociaux démocrates dans le
gouvernement merkel 3 fera bouger les
lignes en en europe notamment sur la
rigueur est ce que ce n'est pas un peut
croire au père noël tout de même mais
moi je n'y crois pas une seconde je
pense que la grande coalition allemande
la grande coalition à demande est une
très mauvaise nouvelle et les
sociaux-démocrates porte une
responsabilité dans la situation qui va
donner davantage de pouvoirs angela
merkel françois hollande d'abord porte
une responsabilité parce que quand il a
gagné l'élection 2012
il avait dit je vais renégocier le pack
budgétaires non seulement il ne l'a pas
renégocié mais il là il a demandé aux
députés de et aux sénateurs de le
ratifier tout de suite résultat on a
offert sur un plateau la victoire
électorale à merkel parce qu'il fallait
ouvrir le débat européen est aujourd'hui
les sociaux démocrates vont dans la
grande coalition alors que je le
rappelle il y avait une autre coalition
possible parce que les
sociaux-démocrates plus die linke qu'il
partait qui est dans le parti de la
gauche européenne avec nous plus les
verts
avait une majorité possible et die linke
avait fait des propositions pour une
majorité une coalition de gauche
l'homme rose rouge vert donc on a laissé
la phr qui va travailler à situer le
choisit une coalition avec merkel
donc il sait c'est une mauvaise nouvelle
pour l'europe il va falloir continuer la
bataille et on voit bien que les
politiques qu'elle veut maintenir vos
bancaire l'une des roquettes est
d'accord m et oui il y en a une deuxième
qui est très significatif de jeu de
nouvelles dont la journée c'est que
l'union de rockeur et signée et standard
and poor ce dégrade la note de l'union
européenne
donc les marchés financiers avec cette
agréable c'est aux insatiables
tant qu'on leur donne pas davantage
d'argent tant qu on draine pas davantage
d'argent vers les marchés financiers ils
ne sont pas satisfaits
donc c'est pas parce qu'on va faire des
risettes aux marchés financiers qu'on va
s'en sortir il faut arrêter avec la dame
de l'union européenne c'est pour ça que
c'est ce que méritent parce que pour
faire pression sur sur les gouvernements
et dire il faut encore nous en donner et
à chaque fois qu'on leur en donne un peu
plus on nous dit faut faire un peu
d'austérité il faut serrer un peu plus
les budgets publics et angela merkel
nous le répète et résultat ils en
demandent encore plus exactement comme
le pas le medef en france donc ces
politiques là elles vont dans le mur
elles sont en train de plonger des
millions et des millions de gens dans la
pauvreté en europe
nous sommes la zone du monde la moins en
développement actuellement l'union
européenne
il faut quand même s'en rendre compte il
ya de la croissance un peu partout dans
le monde
la zone qui n'offre en grèce plus où il
n'y a plus de croissance où il ya un
chômage qui ne cesse de se développer
c'est la zone euro dont il ya bien
quelque chose qui ne va pas et copain de
l'économie je vous propose parle c'est
au budget 2014 qui lui a été votée
la retour aux affaires nationales après
deux mois de débats et un ultime projet
du sénat le projet de loi de finances a
quand même été définitivement votée il
prévoit notamment de réduire de 15
milliards de faire 15 milliards d'euros
d'économies et ainsi que trois milliards
d'euros d'impôts en plus avec aussi des
mesures pour les plus fragiles
pierre laurent sénat votre groupe a donc
voté contre ce budget vous ne rendez pas
service au gouvernement sur un texte
aussi emblématique que le budget mais
parce que ce budget des très mauvais et
on va où va baisser les dépenses plus
attention vous devez pas baisser le
stress ou vers le vent est mauvais ben
c'est pas brillant il s'éclaire et
d'ailleurs c'est ce que pensent les
français et singulièrement ceux qu'ils
ont élus qui ont élu la gauche
il suffit de regarder toutes les
enquêtes d'opinion ou d'aller disputer
dans la surcharge et dépenses publiques
et d un côté on mais pourquoi les
nécessaires mais non parce que l'état
n'a plus non je ne pense qu'au contraire
vous avez un besoin d'investissement
public et on devrait aller chercher des
nouvelles recettes fiscales
mais on va pas les chercher dans les
bonnes poches donc on augmente la tva
c'est à dire l'impôt le plus injuste et
on baisse au fait de nouveaux cadeaux le
crédit d'impôt compétitivité aux
entreprises sans aucune contrepartie en
matière d'emploi donc on continue
d'alimenter un puits sans fond qui
nourrit les logiques financières des
entreprises pour nos impôts à creuser la
dette mais on met mais c'est le chômage
qui creuse la dette c'est que tant qu on
alimentera des politiques de chômage
évidemment les finances publiques vont
se dégrader
puisqu'on ne fait pas de croissance on
crée pas d'emplois eh bien on a pas de
recette
on a pas de recettes pour l'état non
plus c'est normal on baisse l'impôt sur
les sociétés rapport va ne va plus
rapporté que 36 milliards d'euros en
baisse de 12 milliards d'euros l'année
prochaine c'est l'impôt qui rapporte le
moins maintenant sur l'impôt sur les
sociétés les entreprises du cac 40 qui
sont les plus riches ne paient quasiment
pas d'impôt les grands majors américains
comme google amazon et tout ça paye 0 en
pont parce que ils ont leurs comptes
dans des paradis fiscaux
jusqu'à quand va tolérer ça donc c'est
ça le problème l'argent qui manque dans
les dents les dans les caisses de l'état
il faut alors chercher là est ce qu on
entend parler de la situation économique
sur tf1 jeudi soir
oui on va l'écouter puis vous réagirez
juste après cet objectif de l'inversion
de la courbe du chômage nous allons
l'atteindre mais ma volonté et je dis
ici très clairement c'est pas un mois
c'est pas de moi s'est durablement et
l'âge et les éléments qui me permettent
de le dire avait de l'affirmer c'est que
après 5 ans de croissance zéro en
moyenne en france à la fin de l'année
nous retrouvons la croissance très
optimiste prémunissent ou partager cet
optimisme copains moi je mets pas en
doute sa sincérité il m'arrive de
rencontrer jean marc ayrault et d'en
parler je sais bien qu'il est tendue
vers cet objectif mais le problème c'est
que hoang vérité il n'y arrivera pas
parce que justement il n'a pas choisi la
bonne voie il faudrait remettre du
carburant dans l'économie de
l'investissement public en modifiant
d'ailleurs la manière de produire en
construisant papa un nouveau modèle
productif qui intègre les enjeux de la
transition écologique
au lieu de faire ça mais on est sur les
mêmes logiques qu'avant on nous dit faux
faut serrer les budgets publics faut
alléger les les cotisations des
entreprises la réforme fiscale était
rien taquin
elle a mené jusqu'au bout la réforme de
la fiscalité tel que le veut le premier
ministre visiblement françois hollande
pas totalement d'accord
la politique du la détermination du
gouvernement sur cette question n'a pas
l'air très clair mais nous ce que nous
conte ce qui nous que nous avons décidé
nous allons construire ce que j'ai
appelé des états généraux de la justice
fiscale
nous allons faire ça pendant six mois
des ateliers citoyens législatives dans
tout le pays
nous allons mettre mise à l'arrêt de la
réforme fiscale et à la fin du printemps
nous publierons au terme de ces états
généraux de la justice fiscale
une nouvelle loi une proposition de loi
sur laquelle nous nous allons prendre le
sujet au sérieux
je sais pas si le gouvernement va aller
au bout de ses intentions ça a pas l'air
si clair que ça c'est même rien notre
système fiscal dénommé les français les
français ils sont très intelligents les
français faut arrêter de prendre les
français pour des imbéciles
les français comprennent très bien ce
qui se passe ils sont tout à fait
capables de rentrer dans des dossiers
compliqués moi je vais tous les jours
sur le terrain quand vous allez quand
vous faites des
union public vous avez en face d'eux
joue en face de vous des gens très
intelligents qui savent de quoi on parle
les gens sont pas des imbéciles il
suffit qu on ouvre le débat public qu'on
donne à chacun les moyens de comprendre
et tout le monde peut rentrer dans un
débat fiscal qui est pas si j'ai
remarqué cela peut-il mettre en place
toutes ces réformes ce qu'il est encore
crédible il faut qu'ils s'appuient sur
des forces qui ne sont pas les forces
actuelles il il
il envoie on envoie sans arrêt des
signes en direction du patronat des qui
a trois pigeons ou 3 ou trois patrons
qui se manifestent on leur donne
satisfaction
et quand les forces qui ont voulu la
gauche au pouvoir elle se manifeste on
les écoute jamais il faut changer il
faut qu' il faudra vraiment des échanges
et des kits gouvernementale il faut
changer
moi j'ai dit depuis plusieurs mois il
faut changer de politique
changer de méthode et changer d'équipé
revenir aux priorités des français
l'emploi
voilà précisément pôle emploi c'est
notre plus de l'hebdo c'est un
documentaire choc quand vous proposons à
partir du 24 décembre pôle emploi ne
quittez pas une immersion dans le
quotidien des salariés de sept agences
de pôle emploi en région parisienne pour
l'emploi évidemment n'a pas vraiment
apprécié et pour cause vous allez le
voir dans ce résumé que vous propose
simon barbarie
la porte à peine ouverte
ils sont des dizaines à s'engouffrer
dans la salle d'accueil pour l'emploi ne
quittez pas c'est le titre du
documentaire de nora philippe diffusée
sur lcp assemblée nationale la semaine
prochaine pendant 18 mois la
réalisatrice a posé sa caméra dans une
agence de seine saint denis et le
résultat est peu flatteur pour
l'institution lorsqu'apparaissent
notamment des agents noyé dans les
consignes bureaucratique et parfois bien
peu amène envers les demandeurs d'emploi
non ça convient matin convient
l'essentiel c'est que je vous ai répondu
madame
et ben voilà madame sur ce bonne journée
au revoir madame un film qui a fortement
déplu en haut lieu
la direction de pôle emploi a même
décidé d'annuler une projection destinée
à ses agents il est vrai que le
documentaire prend des allures de
désaveu pour tous ceux qui pensaient que
les agents de cette institution publique
devait avoir la fibre sociale comme le
montre cet entretien d'embauché d'un
futur salarié de pôle emploi qui jeux
suivants pour connaître quelqu'un la
première demi heure
en effet il faut du temps pour connaître
les gens mais voilà
proposez c'est vrai que c'est dans le
pays oui oui des bisounours à d'avoir un
entretien avec chaque demandeur d'emploi
toutes les semaines à la peine mais
brèves infos même pas la peine d'y
penser
peu de chômeurs apparaissent à l'écran
dans ce film il aurait pourtant de quoi
se révolter une révolte en partie
illustré dans le web documentaire
intitulé le grand incendie
d'olivia colo et samuel bollendorff en
france une personne s'immole par le feu
tous les quinze jours nous disent les
auteurs un acte extrême et symbolique
d'une violence devenue insupportable
pour certains dans le monde du travail
10h12 aujourd'hui c'est le grand jour
pour moi car je vais me brûler à pôle
emploi
j'ai travaillé 720 heures et la loi c-6
110r les pôles emploi a refusé mon
dossier
un dock de deux documentaires chocs
exceptionnel en même temps ça nous
montre une la réalité telle que telle
qu'elle est très dur et en même temps
est ce que on a vu un extrait avec un
demandeur d'emploi et un employés de
pôle emploi vous vous comprenez que
c'était pas non plus facile tous les
jours
ces agents de ces terribles des deux
côtés moi je me suis rendu à plusieurs
reprises dans des agences de pôle emploi
c'est terrible du côté des chômeurs et
des précaires dont on n'écoute pas la
détresse et ses terribles du côté des
salariés de pôle emploi qui n'ont pas
les moyens de l'accompagner de travail
et qui ne sont pas assez nombreux à qui
on donne de plus en plus de dossiers à
gérer ses troupes à leur pratique pas
s'il n'en met mais surtout ils ont pas
les moyens ils n'ont pas les moyens il
n'arrête pas de le dire ils sont ils
sont au bout du rouleau les agents de
pôle emploi allait discuter avec eux et
au lieu de les écouter eux comme on
devrait écouter les chômeurs eh bien on
met tout le monde et qu'est ce qu'on va
faire on va jeter les uns contre les
autres
et bien cette politique elle est
proprement inhumaine en finir je
voudrais vous demander votre
personnalité de l'année pour 2013 il
avait choisi d'axer mandela si oui
forcément nelson mandela dont je porte
les l'éffigie depuis depuis son décès
parce que ça a été un des combats de ma
vie moi j'ai toujours accompagné ce
combat là ça a été un homme formidable
mais qui a été à la tête d'une lutte
collective
on l'a pas dit assez quand on lui a
rendu hommage il y avait beaucoup de
monde derrière cette lutte la triple
alliance à nc parti communiste sud
africain et syndicat cosatu
c'est ça qui a permis la victoire et
c'est une victoire formidable votre
événement de l'année vous avez choisi
l'acquittement de cinq militants de la
cgt où il y avait cinq militants de
roanne qui était poursuivi pour quelque
chose pour une action syndicale et à qui
on demandait de faire un prélèvement adn
c'est une longue bataille ils sont
acquittés les maintenant on devrait à
l'assemblée nationale adopté la loi
d'aministie social que nous avons
proposé que nous avons voté au sénat que
le gouvernement a bloqué à l'assemblée
on pourrait la beauté maintenant merci
alors on fait katia bonne fête à bientôt
parce que vous reviendrez un petit peu
plus tard durant l'année pour un heureux
événement au mois de mai c'est marion
lefebvre qui sera avec vous bi quels
traits 28 de programme et très bonnes
fêtes sur la chaîne parlementaire
au revoir